this happy in my life in all aspects of
my life as Taylor Swift continues to
live her best life with Matt Healy her
ex Joe Alwyn made his first public
appearance post breakup
the 32 year old looked all kinds of cool
in a black suit satin pink shirt and
shades at a dinner hosted by Celine in
can other Glam guests at the event
Lisa from blackpink BTS star V and Kya
Gerber
also making headlines Tom Hanks as
raving Private Ryan yep there he is with
his wife Rita Wilson at the asteroid
City premiere appearing to be in a
heated argument three to shut down the
speculation Tom lost his cool on
Instagram writing this is called I can't
hear you people are screaming what did
you say where are we supposed to go but
adding to the rage rumor you're not here
the 66 year old skipped the film's press
conference and photo call was Tom mad
nope we're told he wasn't scheduled to
appear to begin with since he does
limited press and we know he's
delivering a speech at Harvard tomorrow
so Tom's name is in the clear but Jude
laws is very guilty of making a stink
quite literally were you allowed to
bathe during shooting I did sometimes in
preparation for his role as Henry VII in
Firebrand Jude admitted he took method
acting to another level at this period
you can smell Henry three rooms away
because his leg was rotting so badly and
he hid it with rose oil so I just
thought it would have a great impact if
I smell awful and um I went to this
brilliant perfumiere and she somehow
managed to come up with this
extraordinary variety which was past
blood
fecal matter
and uh sweat yeah you heard that right
the terrible stench made his co-stars
dry heave on set the film has been well
received at the festival earning an
eight-minute Standing Ovation much like
Natalie Portman's movie May December
[Applause]